the Batman explain your always bored by
the way holy
did you see many movies that yet the
greatest triumph and biggest surprise of
the film is that it is an LSD freakout
on par with 2001 a Space Odyssey
Oh Doctor Strange infinity war damnit
sway Lee and teenagers just the worst
Reynolds has the xylophone ABS devil in
green lanten don't easy easy
well it's smart to now like for soda to
make a superhero fun green lanten it's
pretty legit oh I guess that there is
enough psychology thrown around to keep
film classes in business for years
[Music]
classic it's a groundbreaking Dark
Knight just how hey just doctor yeah
well if you're a drag queen and they
love to share showgirls is your newest
source of inspiration has arrived
yeah 2004 2004 yeah that's right the
beginning is that like superhero movies
one more hand hello a throwback to the
days when superheroes were basically
cheerful gun-toting guys in tights
1996 totally Batman and Robin
but is the Batman explain your I was
born by the way holy how did you see
many movies that yet did anybody see the
no no all right
there's an old jungle saying never point
a gun at me cuz it just might go off
parrots will be flustered uptight
yuppies will be disgusted and fans will
be hopping in their seats with a kind of
joy typically reserved for the next in
line at account at a bouncy castle is
that Deadpool look I'm a teenage girl
I'd rather be anywhere than here
do yourself a favor use the present and
go see this expedition yes 90% fresh
move Thank You Blake is paced like
Quicksilver on crack cocaine holy what
what is it score yet 94% in game yes
that's right
oh go bad news haters blank is good what
did it score
93% fresh Wonder Woman yes whoa yes
thank you nice
[Music]